katia questa volta devo avevo abbastanza
semplici tipo qui le due renne di babbo
natale qui presepe qui un fiocco di neve
l'albero la befana e una fetta di
pandoro o più pc sta bene o fa male e
bene che devo fare invidia mio cugino
katia audio era sicuramente le voglio
grossi però un rosso che non abbia
nessuna non lo so di mi.to non fa un
rosso estivo 90 il rosso babbo natale
che ha una via di mezzo tra il rosso vin
brulé rose l'escort ad essi che rossana
talebana le capisco io non le vogliono e
nere né sberluccicanti sono proiettato
ormai su quando nuovo io voglio nere
come la mia anima e voglio che tu
scrivere una lettera su ogni onda su
questa fox su questa 2021 e nelle dita
che rimangono tumi fare due dito medio
hai capito
kodjo uscendo dalla lampada ho rovinato
sia le renne che bombonato re bomba dai
ci metto due secondi a ripararle